this year marks the 35th anniversary of
metroid the lovable bounty hunting genre
defining child that nintendo loves to
forget about
except to everyone's surprise nintendo
did remember this year and are
celebrating with metroid 5 aka metroid
dread the first brand new 2d metroid
game in
wow that's a long time
so long in fact that there is a whole
generation of people that have never
experienced just how god damn good
classic metroid is
and are looking at all the excitement
dread is causing and they're curious
y'all got a little over a month to catch
up which might seem like a daunting
proposition but i got you so here's what
we're going to do i'm going to go
through each mainline metroid game not
the spin-offs talk about if they're
worth playing and then detail the best
legal way to play them if you can paying
studios for their games is always the
way to go but i know nintendo has no
interest in making much of its older
catalog available on its modern hardware
particularly metro games so you do what
you gotta do for this video i'll detail
the best nintendo approved options
available for you unfortunately that
does mean buying a wii u
ah yes the original metroid the game
that started it all 35 years back on the
nintendo entertainment system you play
as bounty hunter samus aaron tasked with
exploring the planet zebus and
infiltrating the lair of mother brain
leader of these space pirates who are
trying to weaponize deadly creatures
known as metroids metroid was
groundbreaking in its day putting
players in a massive open space with an
unprecedented amount of freedom without
any in-game map to guide you you needed
to make your own this created the sense
of being a true explorer discovering and
mapping out this world for yourself
something only a few games capture it
also makes the plan of zebes feel like a
hostile and alien world you must conquer
the more time you spend playing the
greater your knowledge and mastery
becomes this feeling would grow into a
central component of the metroidvania
genre
while metroid lays the groundwork for
the games to come unfortunately it is a
difficult game to recommend in 2021. the
lack of a map is certainly a part of the
appeal but this does create a much
higher barrier of entry for those that
don't have the patience it doesn't help
that certain progression is gated by
lucking your way into hidden paths that
can be near impossible to find without a
guide it's also just really difficult in
a more frustrating than fun kind of way
it's really easy to find yourself
lacking enough missile ammo for a boss
or needing to spend time grinding out
health drops from enemies with dying
kicking you all the way back to the
start of the level without refilling
your supply it's not to say you can't
enjoy this game but it demands a level
of patience most players don't have
these days and i would only recommend it
to those that are interested in its
challenge but if you are that kind of
person or at least want to check it out
for yourself this is a pretty easy one
to get your hands on without having to
buy a cart on ebay if you have a
nintendo online subscription you get
metroid as a part of the selection of
nest games available there's even
versions that start you at the fight
against ridley or turian other options
for playing metroid include buying it
digitally on the 3ds or the wii u
it's also a part of the nes classic
but good luck finding one of those for a
reasonable price these days
metroid 2 return of samus wouldn't
release on home consoles but rather on
nintendo's handheld the game boy
your goal is to eradicate all of the
metroids on the planet sr388
the species home world using your
metroid detector you must explore the
planet to find and kill every metroid
much of what makes metroid metroid is
still here a large open-ended map to
explore secrets to uncover and new
abilities and upgrades to find but all
in the palm of your hand and yes metroid
2 was an impressive experience for a
handheld back then but the
considerations needed to make it work on
the game boy or what hold it back today
the limited pixels rendered on screen
make the game feel claustrophobic and
the world hard to navigate despite being
a simpler map this time around and while
the game's metroid evolutionary stages
which make up the bosses you encounter
are pretty cool they do often repeat and
quickly become repetitive it's not a bad
game but it's not noteworthy enough to
recommend today you're better off
playing one of its several remakes
either the official 3ds one which we'll
talk about later or the brilliant fan
make am2r
just don't tell nintendo however if you
are interested in checking out metroid 2
return of samus your only official
option outside of owning an original
copy is to pick it up on the nintendo
3ds for 3.99
but now we move on to the big one
it's kind of hard to know what to say
considering so much has already been
said about the legendary super metroid
it takes everything about the original
metroid expands it and refines it
creating what many consider to be one of
the greatest games ever made in defining
the genre that would later be known as
metroidvania the interconnected map of
zebes features some brilliant level
design and is a master class at expertly
guiding the players through the game
without telling you where to go next
hidden secrets and upgrades slowly open
up more to explore giving you this
wonderful sensation of becoming more
powerful and mastering the game the
hallmarks of what make a great
metroidvania all started right here with
super metroid what's most impressive to
me about super metroid is how
contemporary it feels there have been
plenty of improvements to the
metroidvania genre over the years but so
much of what that genre is was defined
by super metroid so most of the game's
mechanics boss and level designs and
story don't feel dated they could have
been released only a few years ago and
it would have easily fit right at home
with the other modern day metroidvanias
super metroid ends up being a perfect
example that just because a game is old
doesn't mean it feels old it's a classic
for a reason and you should absolutely
give it a try if you're interested in
this series thankfully it's also really
easy to get like with metroid 1 if you
have a nintendo online subscription you
have access to super metroid on the
nintendo switch you can also pick it up
on the nintendo 3ds or wii u for 7.99
the series would then rotate back to the
handheld for metroid 4 called metroid
fusion but unlike metroid 2 fusion would
be released on the game boy advance
which was powerful enough to bring snes
level quality on the go
fusion is a great game albeit it's very
different to super metroid in some key
ways while much of the metroid formula
remains the game is far more linear in
structure with a set order of objectives
you'll never be confused where to go
next as samus has her ship ai telling
her where to go and what her objective
is this leaves the open exploration for
gathering extra upgrades this can be a
major turn off for those that enjoy
player freedom as part of a metric
experience but it's still extremely well
done and comes with the benefit of a
more involved story and scripted moments
fusion is the first metro title to
really push its narrative in a major way
outside of its opening you'll hear samus
ponder her feelings during elevator
rides and she frequently interacts with
her ship ai adam fusion also delves into
horror most famously with the sax a
parasite that has taken over samus's
original suit and stalks you throughout
the game
fusion's combat is also superb the
controls all have a much tighter feel
than super metroid and it feels so damn
good to play it also makes up for its
more linear structure by being rather
difficult outside of a few moments super
metroid isn't all that difficult but
fusion on the other hand is the toughest
of the classic metroids but like in a
good way fusion is on the opposite end
of the metroid experience when compared
to super metroid and the game often gets
overlooked probably because it was
released within a day of metroid prime
but i think fusion is also one of the
more unique metroid experiences and
absolutely worth playing unfortunately
fusion is one of the more difficult
metroid titles to get your hands on you
can only play it on the 3ds if you
happen to be part of the 3ds ambassadors
program back in 2011 for those of you
who remember that and otherwise there
have been no official plans to release
the game on the nintendo switch
but you are in luck if you happen to own
a wii u where it is available for 7.99
the emulation of gba games on the wii u
is actually really good in my opinion
and it does make a great place to play
fusion in fact after the announcement of
metro dread fusion topped the charts on
the wii u store page along with the
other metroid gba title xero mission
a remake of the original metroid zero
mission takes all of the improvements
from super metroid and the smooth combat
of fusion and applies it to the first
game and it is magnificent i said
earlier that you can safely skip the
original metroid and that's because you
should play zero mission instead i have
a special place in my heart for this
game as it was actually my first ever
metroid title and what made me fall in
love with the series in the first place
in fact i think it's actually the
perfect place to start it carries over
the objective waypoints of fusion while
also being more open-ended sort of a
middle ground between that game and
super metroid it's also not as difficult
as fusion striking what i think is a
perfect balance it may not be as
open-ended as super metroid but i think
it's such a beautifully paced game and
one that shouldn't be missed just like
with fusion your only official option is
to pick it up on the wii u store
hopefully nintendo releases zero mission
and fusion on other platforms like the
switch before the wii u store inevitably
closes and these amazing titles are lost
to time
we still got one more 2d metroid to talk
about near the end but the release of
zero mission marked the end of classic
2d metroid games for the time the series
transitioned over to 3d during the 2000s
with the metroid prime trilogy if you're
watching this video specifically because
of your interest in dread the prime
games are kind of their own thing and
maybe more relevant to check out closer
to the release of metroid prime 4 but
that doesn't mean the prime games should
be passed up developer retro studios did
what was thought to be impossible at the
time and translated metroid into a 3d
space without losing what made it
special you would think the switch to a
first person perspective would turn
metroid into a more action shooter title
but in reality it's a first person
adventure all about exploring
platforming puzzle solving with combat
only playing one part just like with the
rest of the series by being directly
behind the eyes of samus prime is able
to add new elements like multiple visors
including a scanning feature that gives
you information about all the objects
and creatures in the world due to the
one analog stick nature of the gamecube
prime has a unconventional control
scheme that might throw new players off
but the game is built in such a way that
this works perfectly you can feel the
weight of the massive suit samus has to
walk around in and i'm hard pressed to
think of another game that connects you
to the character you're playing through
the movement the way metroid prime does
there really just aren't any other games
like it
all three games are excellent and worth
your time it might be tricky if you want
to play the original gamecube versions
of the first two as your only option is
to find used copies your easiest option
is the metroid prime trilogy collection
for the wii a great package that
remastered the first two games with
motion controls the wii controls are
actually quite good but it's
understandable if the very idea of
motion controls is off-putting to you
maybe someday we'll finally get that
switch port we keep hearing rumors about
but for now you can pick up metroid
prime trilogy on the wii u for 19.99
i did say i was gonna talk about all the
mainline metroid games which means i do
have to mention metroid other m up until
this point the metroid series has had a
pretty great track record even the ones
i don't recommend metroid 1 and 2 they
aren't bad games they just haven't aged
the best other m was a mess from day one
and it has earned a reputation as not
only the worst metroid but at the time
it seemed to be responsible for the
death of the franchise other m's biggest
selling point and also its biggest
problem is the story other m goes even
further than fusion did making cutscenes
and dialogue a major part of the game
it's the kind of shift that makes
metroid into something it's not and the
story that is there isn't very good with
some really rough voice acting
particularly from actor jessica aaron
martin who voices samus thanks to the
hyper beam
which was given to me somehow by the
baby a baby baby the baby the baby the
baby this would be forgivable if the
gameplay was good but unfortunately it
suffers from a force controller scheme
gimmick you can only play the game with
a wiimote no numchuck so you run around
holding the wii more horizontally using
the d-pad to move in a 3d environment
which yes is as awkward and
uncomfortable as it sounds during combat
you can adjust the wiimote vertically
switching the view from third person to
first person where you then have more
precise aiming enemies but can no longer
move
which again is as awkward as it sounds
the game has a lot of other issues with
its design like a severe reduction in
exploration but for me the fundamental
act of playing this game is so awkward
and uncomfortable i would say avoid it
for that reason alone but if you are
interested your only option outside of
buying a physical copy is the wii u
store for 19.99
and finally we wrap back around to 2d
metroid with 2017's samus returns
co-developed by nintendo and mercury
steam best known for the castlevania
lords of shadow series samus returns is
a remake of metroid 2 for the nintendo
3ds the game sticks to the classic side
scrolling perspective but this time with
3d graphics the game remains faithful to
the spirit of the original while tuning
its map and design to the style of super
metroid a number of new features for the
series are added such as full 360 degree
aiming and the inclusion of a melee
counter move this gives the combat a
slightly faster more action feel and
makes samus that much deadlier overall
metroid samus returns is an excellent
return to form for the series it gets a
strong recommendation from me
particularly if you're interested in
dread which is also being developed by
mercury steam and carries over the same
gameplay style established here right
now the game is only available for the
3ds with a digital copy running you
39.99 let's hope that nintendo will one
day port the game over to the switch
so there you have it we have 10 mainline
metroid games with seven that i would
personally recommend checking out which
yeah is still a lot however if your
interest is to solely get caught up for
metroid dread you can ignore the prime
trilogy for now and save those closer to
the release of metroid prime 4. four
games still seems like a lot in only a
month's time so i'm gonna kind of give a
recommendation for why i think each one
is worth checking out and you can decide
for yourself first up is metroid zero
mission like i said i think it is the
perfect starting point for the series
it's a great game it's a great
introduction to metroid without being
too difficult but also still having some
of that exploration to it the only thing
is that it's kind of tough to get your
hands on without a wii u and because of
that i think the overall best one to
pick up is super metroid it's the game
that started it all it's a classic for a
reason and it's really easy to get your
hands on if you have a nintendo switch
and you have an online account you have
super metroid next up i would recommend
samus returns it does require you to
have a nintendo 3ds and it is the most
expensive of all of these games here but
it is the one that is going to feel the
most like metroid dread because it's
developed by that same studio is
carrying over a lot of those same
mechanics and finally fusion i recommend
this one because of the story it is the
game that canonically takes place right
before
metroid dread and because of that a lot
of the events of fusion are going to
carry over to that game specifically
samus's ai ship adam is making a return
along with the sax so there's a lot of
connections between those games and if
that's what you're interested in you
should definitely at least check out
fusion of course if you just want to get
fully caught up on the story of fusion
we actually have a complete metroid
timeline in the works that will break
down everything you need to know about
samus aaron and her many adventures i'll
be sure to provide a link to it once
it's released all right everybody those
are my recommendations if there's
anything you take away from this video
play some dang metroid games metroid
games are great it's my favorite
nintendo franchise and i really just
think you can't go wrong thanks for
watching everybody i'll see you next
time